a portion of this video is sponsored by
kiwiko
hello my name is dominic i've got a phd
in quantum physics and i made a video
for youtube explaining quantum mechanics
and a lot of the people in the comments
were saying who's here because of
ant-man
and it turns out in ant-man they talk
about quantum physics i guess because he
shrinks down really small i haven't
actually seen the movie yet
i've been meaning for a long time to to
watch it and see what the quantum
mechanics is like in the movie so that's
what we're going to do
today is take a look and see how they
did
[Music]
dr hank pym
you know this is good because it's
called future lab that's where
futuristic things happen
when i took over this company for dr pim
i immediately started researching a
particle that could change the distance
between atoms
while increasing density and strength
okay so what he said was
i've discovered a particle that can
change the distance between
atoms while increasing the density
and the strength so is that possible
basically no the thing that sets the
size of atoms and the distances between
atoms
is not the stuff that makes up the atoms
it's the forces between them and it's
like the fundamental forces of nature so
uh the distance between atoms is set by
the electromagnetic force of the
electrons
so to change the distance between atoms
in
water with mostly water you'd have
to actually change the strength of that
electromagnetic force
and and that's like one of the
fundamental laws of the universe and so
you're basically like
as soon as you hit like i need to to do
my thing
i need to change a fundamental law of
the universe you're like yeah you can't
really do your thing
sorry um my job isn't to
just criticize the physics in these
movies because clearly they need to come
up with some fantastical reason why
the crazy stuff in these movies is
happening
so i don't mind if the physics is a bit
wonky my job is really to
see if there's a better explanation
using actual science to justify the
things that they're doing
so is there a way of maintaining
the forces of nature but decreasing the
size of a
human body do you need to somehow
reconfigure the atoms that you've got
into like
a miniature version of that and then
sort of like throw away
99 of your you know
atoms and cells in your body and that's
going to be pretty
disturbing to watch for a
kids movie um but also he's been a bit
imprecise with his language there
because he said
that could change the distance between
atoms i can change the distance
between atoms while increasing density
increasing
density and strength you can't increase
the distance between atoms while
increasing the density things get less
dense when they get further
apart which makes me slightly suspect
about this guy
if he's supposed to be the crackpot
scientist he's making basic language
mistakes like that
i've got limited
confidence in his abilities also i'm
getting a real
strong like bad guy villain vibe
from this guy he looks kind of a bit
like jeff bezos
i don't think you understand
okay well he's dead now isn't he we
still haven't worked out so um
yeah that's more what i was thinking
along the lines of in terms of
reducing the size of a human would sort
of be that kind of scenario
oh megan it's a carbondale it's from
1910.
made for the same steel as the titanic
well here's the thing
it doesn't do so well in the cold so
what's he doing
pumping up an air bed
pouring water in a hole put water in the
locking mechanism and froze it with
nitrogen
ice expands metal doesn't
all right let's just unpack what
happened there so what he did was
he drilled a hole in the safe he poured
a load of water in
sprayed it with nitrogen and that
exploded the door
[Music]
so i think what he's going for is that
he froze the water
but it looked like he had a compressed
nitrogen
canister just which just sprays out
nitrogen
i think what they wanted was liquid
nitrogen liquid nitrogen
is nitrogen gas cooled down until it's a
liquid and it's a
you know 4.2 kelvin so that's really
cold
it can freeze water if water froze
because water expands by i can't
remember
just a little bit five percent or
something
that expanding water would be enough to
then explode the door off the hinges
steel is so strong that even expanding
ice is not going to smash it it's also a
bit flexible it does bend
so i don't i mean you're certainly not
going to have it exploding off
the hinges like that
there is a way i think there is a way of
doing this using all of the same
stuff but instead of putting the water
in first
you put the liquid nitrogen in first and
then put the water on top
and what would happen is the
water would form an ice seal like an ice
cap
and as liquid nitrogen evaporates
because the surrounding temperature of
the door is so
hot in comparison to 4.2 kelvin it all
turns into a gas and that increases the
pressure
by massively i think the volume of
nitrogen increases by 40 times when it
boils off into a gas
future editing dom here i just fact
checked that fact and it turns out i was
wrong
in fact when liquid nitrogen expands
into a gas it expands by
nearly 700 times which is a lot more
than 40 times which i just said
which makes what i'm about to say even
more true
and then that pressure could build up
enough to blow off
the steel door potentially i think
that's more feasible so using all the
same stuff as long as he's using liquid
nitrogen
instead of just nitrogen compressed
nitrogen
that is a feasible way of actually
blowing off a door so that's what they
should have gone for and i know this is
true because they used to
work with cryogenic liquids like liquid
nitrogen
in these big dewars which are thermos
flasks
sort of giant thermos flasks which you'd
wheel around
and they've got um a safety release
pressure valve
for this very reason is that the
nitrogen inside is constantly boiling
off and so you need to release the gases
but they've got other inlets for you to
like
put um tubes in to remove the liquid
nitrogen or put it in
and for those we were all always told
you should never leave them open to the
air
because what happens is that the water
vapor in the air
will condense out of the air and start
forming an icy layer on top of the
liquid nitrogen
and if that layer of ice gets bigger and
bigger once it's about two inches
then that's sealed and now it's just
a time bomb an ice bomb
that will increase in pressure over time
and eventually it will explode outside
of
the the metal dewa and this
actually happened to someone not when i
was working i heard a story of this
happening to someone in a lab
where they had done this exact thing
and they got a phone call saying that
their lab had just
been destroyed by an exploding doer that
actually took out an entire wall of
their lab
so those things can be uh
yeah that's how to make a bomb out of
water and nitrogen
so you should have done that there you
go
i should become a cat burglar the only
thing is
it would have taken like hours for it to
increase
to enough pressure to do that but you
know maybe he could have heated it up
with a hair dryer
[Music]
oh it's so cute oh no
it got squished sanitize the workstation
bring in subject 35c
definitely that's exactly what jeff
bezos would have said
would you like some sugar yeah thanks
how do you make them do that i use
electromagnetic waves
to stimulate their olfactory nerve
center
so their olfactory nerve center is like
olfaction is smell so he's using
electromagnetic waves to
tell them to smell things and that makes
them move sugar cubes
guess if he's communicating with the
olfactory nerve center that's actually
the bit in his
in in the ants brains not like the no
it's just like electromagnetic waves up
the nose does not make sense
but yeah if he if he's transmitting
signals directly into their brains
that's okay i mean i say okay i'm not
sure you can use electromagnetic waves
to um
trigger nerve
firing
no you can't you can't do that
so electromagnetic waves go from radio
waves through
infrared microwaves
visible light uv and then up to x-rays
and gamma rays
and all of those either go through us
like radio waves
or at the other end gamma rays or they
get absorbed
and they'll get absorbed by our skin so
there's no way you can get an
electromagnetic wave to go
through a few layers of skin and skull i
mean exoskeleton
and and hit as precise nerve especially
if you're doing it from one hearing aid
you need two hearing aids at least to
focus in on the thing
i mean the only way is you get every
single ant and you put a microchip in it
and then you um
sort of talk to your little microchip
with your hearing aid
people can do that with cockroaches i
think you can buy your own remote
control cockroach kit
which is where you get all the
electronics and you just basically stab
something into the cockroach's nervous
system and you can control it walking
around
super freaky i hope that's true
i've just seen it on the internet and
you know what the internet's like
uh maybe i'll fax check that one here
[Music]
you know i think this regulator is
holding do not
screw with the regulator if that
regulator is compromised
you would go subatomic don't mess with
the regulator
or you might enter the quantum realm
okay this is where we get into the
quantum physics
uh what he said was it means that you
would enter a quantum realm
what does that mean it means that you
would enter a reality where all concepts
of time
and space become irrelevant as you
shrink
for all eternity that's not true at all
everything in quantum mechanics is
described very well
uh the the mystery in it comes about
because we can't predict exactly where
things are
but we know as a distribution of where
they
could be and so electrons aren't point
like
things in in the quantum realm which
isn't like a place or anything which is
what i think they're going for
you go to this place particles are
described by
things called wave functions which are
spread out in space
and they're probabilistic they can make
predictions of where particles will turn
up
but they're not definite you don't
exactly know where everything is but it
doesn't mean that everything's
completely meaningless time and space
don't mean anything anymore
they still do time still carries on yeah
so the quantum realm
is not how he described it to be
so is there something in quantum physics
that is
like what he described and and there
kind of
is but you have to go even further below
the quantum realm
quantum realm is really just the
description of the the size
range where quantum effects start
appearing
which is once you get down to
a few nanometers and things like
superposition entanglement tunneling
those things happen but if you go even
further down
to even smaller distances and
um and smaller energies you get down to
the scale of the planck length
and there weird stuff does happen that
you can't describe
because you're below the limits of a
thing called the heisenberg
uncertainty principle when you're below
the heisenberg and certainty principle
limit
things anything can happen and you can't
predict anything so particles virtual
particles will spontaneously
exist and then annihilate
and like anything can happen below that
limit
and so that's what they should have gone
for they should have gone for
if you go if you keep shrinking down
below the plank length
then blah blah blah blah and he could
have carried on
so that would have been my feedback
[Music]
okay let me tell you about kiwi comb
kiwico boxes contain
really cool projects designed to expose
kids to concepts in steam
subjects which is science technology
engineering art and mathematics
and each monthly crate contains a brand
new project exploring
different themes for example in this
tinker crate i've made this animation
machine
and it comes with a really nicely
designed magazine
which explores the science of moving
pictures
and expands on the subject which is very
appropriate for this video
i love the combination of having a
hands-on project with
additional educational material that
that is fun and engaging and doesn't
feel like you're
sitting through a lesson each box comes
with everything you need to build the
project so you don't have to worry about
not having the right
materials or anything like that and this
is just one line
of crates there are eight different
subscription lines each
aimed at a different age group and
different interests
so if you've got kids in your life who
you think would enjoy this
check out kiwico there's a link in the
description
below they now ship to 40 countries
around the world
and they're offering you a 50 discount
off your first
box if you subscribe via my link
kiwico.com
dos and that applies to any of their
different lines of crate
look at that i loved stuff like this
back in my day
i'm gonna have to shrink between the
molecules to get in there
i love you cassie
so he has to shrink between the
molecules to get in there he's not
shrinking between molecules yet because
you can
still see wires and stuff
everything looks like viruses
you would enter a reality
okay so that was a big zooming down in
size sequence
and i i guess i was trying to like
visually
interpret all of the things that he was
zooming into
all the time and it looked like he
because at one time it
had that model of an atom with the with
the electrons orbiting around
unfortunately that's not what atoms look
like that's a bit of a
very much a simplification cartoon so
there's much better ways of drawing
atoms
to be technically correct but perhaps
that is the visual language that most
people understand so maybe that is a
good choice just for people
to understand here's an atom but um
i mean the trouble i have is he was
saying
i'm going in between the molecules
i'm gonna have to shrink between the
molecules to get in there and
he had already been going between the
molecules for a long time before we hit
an atom
as soon as you're going in between
molecules you should be at the scale of
atoms
right so all the other stuff as he was
zooming down was like
it looked like zooming in on materials
and
a lot of stuff looked like viruses and
the reason he needed to go
into molecular was because the guy's
armor was made
of titanium right as if titanium's any
more special than
steel or anything else titanium's just a
lattice of
titanium atoms and also
after he got through the titanium he's
going through all the electronics where
you can see literal wires
so how is he small enough to get through
the titanium but then suddenly big
enough to be amongst all the wires
maybe i'm being overly pedantic with
this whole sequence the point of the
sequence is just to
show he's getting smaller and that's
fine
what was interesting actually was when
he got down to the really small scales
and now he's trapped in the quantum
realm
what's going on there what they're
really trying to do here
is visualize what
the quantum realm looks like when you're
subatomic
and this is a genuinely hard thing to do
i don't think it's it's it's
it's really possible we don't have any
way of seeing down at that scales
for a start you're smaller than the
wavelength of light which is around
400 nanometers which is way bigger than
an atom so you can't
see colors or anything as we perceive
them
you can make out features using other
microscopes like electron microscopes
or atomic force microscopes you can see
features below them when you're below
atoms
the only way you can see smaller than
that is using particle colliders
and then you're actually smashing atoms
together and seeing what comes out
you can't actually like go down into an
atom and see what it looks like there's
no microscopes that can give you like a
movie or a picture of what that looks
like so visualizing that the best thing
we could do is take
the laws of um quantum physics so
so quantum field theory and do a
visualization of quantum field theory
and actually this whole floating around
in a nebula is not the worst
kind of thing because it's sort of
portraying that there's
some tendrils of something yeah
it's really hard to visualize that it
would be like
multiple overlapping fields that were
wobbling
and maybe some of them would have little
excitations passing which would be like
particles wobbling in
in the fields and the one the one shot i
quite liked was when
he was interacting with that geometrical
shape
and he kind of blurred into multiple
versions of himself
now that is quite a nice visualization
of
how we could interpret a particle is in
the quantum realm because it's in
a variety of possible different states
and we don't know which one it's in
or actually it's not actually in one it
is spread out
over all of these states and so i think
that would be the key
visual element when you're subatomic in
the quantum realm
is to have multiple copies of yourself
that are a bit see through which
which shows that now probability now
you're dominated by a probability of a
position rather than a specific position
because that would have been cool right
as he gets smaller and smaller
he starts diverging right and then he
has to like pull himself together
because he loves his daughter so much
and then that could have been a visual
metaphor for him like
pulling himself together and then he
gets big again
so how would i rate this it's a really
hard thing to do
and they did fine
[Music]
okay that's it for ant-man if you want
to find out more about
quantum physics from my videos i'm
linking the
the main one here and then there's
another one which is the map of quantum
physics
i also make posters of that so you can
buy that as a poster
on my store on dftba and i think i've
got a whole playlist of quantum physics
videos as well
if you're interested in diving deeper
otherwise
thanks for watching and i'll see you on
the next one
[Music]
i'm gonna have to shrink between the
molecules to get in there
you